i think
i'm still deeply troubled by his parlor
being removed from aws
that changed the way i that changed a
lot of things as
somebody who's an aspiring entrepreneur
that changed the way i see the world
that little maybe i'm being overdramatic
but no you're not
i think you're paranoid for a reason
you're paranoid for a very good reason
which is as big as these companies can
become
they are beholden to the mob and if the
mob says
hey this person needs to be canceled
they're going to get cancelled because
you can't lose your entire audience you
can lose your whole customer base and
you can lose all your employees
i think what's interesting about your
fear about parlor and aws taking off is
we went from being like a social network
which is
you know the software layer and then we
went to like the infrastructure layer
you know and they'll even go after like
cloudflare which is a cdn provider right
they're just like
a plumbing you know it's like sort of
like the telephone
so we're basically holding everybody
responsible
on the whole chain of events here what
that's going to do is you know
i'm not a huge believer in crypto but
distributed computing
where nobody and decentralized and
distributed
computing platforms and open standards
podcasting's an open standard
the web is an open standard ftp was an
open standard but twitter
and you know facebook are closed
and what's going to happen is we will
see a group of individuals create
peer-to-peer networks for social media
where nobody can control it and the same
for cloud computing
where you know there's a there's a
a crypto project where everybody will
and i invested in a company that tried
to do this and
um got sold and it didn't work out but
take your hard drive on your computer at
home you give
you know a terabyte of your 10 terabyte
drive over to the cloud
and then everybody else does their
terabyte and then all of a sudden you've
got this virtual cloud
and anybody can store stuff on it and
it's all encrypted and then nobody can
stop it
and that could be tweets it could be
videos and so this idea that
you know youtube will be able to tell
people to kick people off because
they're skeptics of
i don't know the pandemic or the vaccine
or they've
you know they'll make things that are
more censorship resistant i think
that'll be the reaction to all of this
you